it's pretty talk about you and your
animals you had Peter tell us how's your
animal stories I want to hear these from
you are you this guy what's up buddy
well Tiger the line there's totally two
different species of animals they
conduct themselves differently my line
is more you can domestic family with the
family and everything the tiger I'm
wounded depends on you individually and
the one else interesting Wow if you ever
had any uh memorable moments with your
animals that you just cherished like oh
man one day we hung on the pool or song
the only thing soon did touch the water
that's when they [ __ ] yeah oh really a
lot of animals do that I can't have that
much fun with them you get really good
in the pool with like you know they
could carry me on their back and still
swim oh you're on grow strong as hell
yeah I love the water
I'm a they dive deep in Jaguars to your
stuff with the Jaguars in South America
when they jump and crash the crocodiles
yeah I love thank dude it's amazing then
they carry it out yeah that's why I love
Jags you know yeah they're this don't
give a [ __ ]
[Music]